I give me all okay so this is incredible
now what we've done is we take in the
two hundo what do they call joy buzzer
icons yeah we've taken a few icons and
we connected them but you love it and
they we connected them into one
controller you see that we switched the
joy Khan's into a controller whatever
they tell with that yeah nice
all right okay there's that I put them
on my daughter's account because I don't
want him messing up oh he fell in the
water I give it all the swimming okay
Jim swimming now wait I'm turning the
angle I'm turning around all I see right
oh I want to hang out in the lily pads
living in lily pads but my supposed to
deal with [ __ ] go gone drew get out
of the water
I'm trying there's a rock you just fell
off a rock into the water
all right cool how do I get up out of
there don't give any tips oh there you
go
I'm climbing up okay you're climbing up
it's now first-person perspective and
we're looking at the rock okay I like
being away now look what you found
whoa what's that other is Zelda I know
I'm getting away from there I wanna go
back in the water I know what's in it
well what is that like just foul now
link just found a sword hold on but then
a link ran away from those elder well
guys I keep off the [ __ ] rock go eat
Jimmy straight time with real mossy is
that what the problem is yes yeah come
on now you're just jumping at the wrong
how do you get on it you can't get on
the rock no I can't [ __ ] rocks I
can't I'm trying he's just jumping on
the rock because there's no way to get
on it's broken no it's validating all
right I'm off but now I'm gonna go over
there I gotta grab how do you grab
something it says what it says on the
street a take with the [ __ ] a Wow
rusty broadsword yeah we can say some
don't make you [ __ ] all right now what do
I do with the rusty broadsword weapon
put it in your ass yeah you do now why
be you have a weapon now okay you get it
you could have climbed down BG's well
water the [ __ ] climate a water bucket
of water
all right so you can swim around the
pond yep yeah
I cool this game is fun you like this
thing I do so far yeah okay good so you
have a rusty broadsword near swimming
yeah I think of any if Jim would still
like any game it would be an open-world
game like this where you could do
anything you want
yeah although you ended in the swimming
you're going to run out of stamina and
die in a second oh my god
is that what that meter isn't second I'm
[ __ ] I wouldn't get I wish you hadn't
told them I don't care okay my give me
the round
jimsy Straus big heel he drown in the
pond that picked up that dog [ __ ] sword
okay now you're back on a rock and
you're back in the water okay and Link
just a very very unethically how I get
up he slid down the rock into the water
that was little climbing down I didn't
mean to do that it was an Amazon
something you just fell in the water
okay okay just standing in the water
there okay climbing climbing hit B oh
okay Knight is jumping all right babies
Cera's he's joining us is leash hold on
yeah I don't know how you did it there's
no way to climb this [ __ ] rock yeah
well I know that I'm same rock he's up
he's back on the example I know I wanna
go out the other side I don't want to be
alive anymore come into the water again
in the water again he jumped off that's
the same rock where you proven that you
can hit we actually dipped you up there
like golf it was also killing your
stamina cockatiel yeah oh there's a fish
in the water he's back in the lily pads
it also there we go okay cool it's just
a rock wall okay now climb up the wall
he picked those I died again
how are you be sucker I take it off some
my rock why would you pick the flattest
surface to climb up I didn't know what
it was don't you think that might be a
little more difficult like dude maybe
some of the smaller line down alright
alright he's on top of the rock again
I'm trying to climb - why is this piece
of [ __ ] when you hit the but that
doesn't go
he died twice get off the [ __ ] ride
twice already and he's losing stamina
quickly yeah the water cool now how do i
where's land I want to be a landlubber
he just slipped again and Finn slipped
down the right to the land
hit the water there we go look at that
he's just standing in the
there's no [ __ ] land not Jim this is
gonna sound crazy I probably shouldn't
even be giving you this tip but what if
you just jumped on that small rock for
what you stood there to regain your
stamina oh how it works yeah I mean yes
like real life how about this blonde
hair [ __ ] doesn't just swim and drowns
you just crawled going 70 feet did you
just call link a blond-haired [ __ ] [ __ ]
link today okay you got it you got game
over at rental you got to continue all
right wait you get game over but then
you can continue from where you left off
yeah
it's not exactly game over well I mean
that is whatever what I hear if you're
fighting a guy oh why did I when you get
a bad man oh all right I don't hear we
don't get to get off the rock in the
water
great watch oh he's on the rock what I
wanted this for but what does be for
let's find out go what you do yeah it's
sweet again look yeah [ __ ] yeah swinging
an actress we're gonna max where'd you
get the axe from I thought I got a sort
I think Riley found that earlier I made
your weapon [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah
you just jump up and down our this is
awesome so he's taking advantage of the
progress your seven-year-old daughter is
made yeah I mean how do I get out of
there they just jumped in the water onto
rocks I mean I don't help no no sorry a
lot you guys how many go up here why I
gave you an INT already oh look at that
good what a fun game I can stand on the
rock okay I can regain your salmon I
don't give a [ __ ] Jim look ahead does it
look like it might be easier to get up
on land where the green grass is then
maybe where that big giant flat rock
wall won't you mind your B flats way a
[ __ ] climbers [ __ ] okay oh
you're on land yes I am your ally lover
again yeah [ __ ] yeah
he said now now he's just I'm [ __ ]
cutting the grass yeah cut that [ __ ]
launch if he's cut right now watch I
walk around link is in front of a giant
rock just swinging his axe
this is so [ __ ] come on Khan client
if you can't get up no no yeah okay now
I go what okay how do I get around the
wall
don't worry about never use it all over
go to the water why do one or two of
these joysticks only one one for the
camera wants to move her so the one on
the right will will move your can't see
you're on land I'm using both at the
same time he lead leading I'm just
running along they're kind of cool
you made out of the water that's cool
right walking up stairs using I'm
running up the steps get in shape looks
like you did a role of an ancient castle
oh there's a guy there's a guy there's a
guy right there
sweet guy hold I'm gonna take this [ __ ]
[ __ ] kill the guy give me that [ __ ] he
killed a big red guy you know what that
proves people really are tougher than
the depth that's true that's the woman
who didn't show up for today there you
go now watch now I'm just standing my
spoils no it shows you your inventory
you're telling you what you got we got a
[ __ ] I'm in the boku Club big deal no
yeah is a boku Club what the weapon is a
club Oh during the boku Club hahaha I
didn't know what that was
no that's oh yeah I was almost a member
but I spelled it wrong alright now what
do I do today and keep going don't worry
I can't eat it no no it's an I can't
read it okay ah I'm he's not dead you
just you just took his boku Club
mother's country I guess that meter in
front of him would be uh how do i
[ __ ] kill this now it's yeah I am so
what what's this I take it yeah
let's find out Oh are there I got a buck
hobbling Fang oh you got abakada Lin
saying dude cool I was wondering I'm
gonna be actually you dope type of the
actually don't worry about it I just
checked tested my measures he's just
walking around with the axe now he's got
a boku Club he's got some Lutheran fangs
I've never in the Boca Club and I all
what a nice member a member of the boku
and it'll pay my dues and [ __ ] now I'm
just running I'm running up these steps
this is fun for no one by the way what
do you think by the way what do you what
do you think of this ancient castle that
you're exploring oh it does I'm not
awake again
oh no look at what it's giving you the
option to do I can't read him
oh it was greening the option to pray
I'm gonna pray for what if you hit a you
could pray no I mean we gotta pray just
to make it to this
cool now what how do I change the
[ __ ] camera angle there we go alright
alright there it is cool this is all
this is first person well no because you
were just you change the camera angle so
it's like on top of you I think it's
super close to a wall that makes first
person you don't yes why would you be
able to never just be fun it's not a
first-person game it's just I don't know
I'm learning he's I guess I'm learning
like a boy Deva don't don't let him
learn don't shame him for learning I
know don't Shive been shamed about
enough things in my life stop put the
actual you ass home and he did
completely fall off the castle did I
yeah just now am I in the castle would
that your get back in there your sir
it's the ruins of a castle but what is
it look at it look at all these say what
are these skeletons of monsters or
something but am I supposed to do with
them Explorer obviously don't explore
these I mean wouldn't you explore a new
land look at it even if you hit a you
can search it look what you found what
you find an ancient spring hey ah you'll
need that later no I long for what give
to the lady in the first village where
is this base I can fill it no spoilers
sorry what spoilers I can't get off the
[ __ ] out of the grass enter oh now
what Wow you tell me it's an open world
I don't know dude I'm can I go up there
you know where every well how do I get
to the rules swim well how does one get
up to the roof and roll in like one fine
steps
don't forget the ceiling is the roof as
the great Michael Jordan once said the
ceiling is the roof okay okay what are
we doing here all right looks like we're
just jumping up and down in front of a
column there's no way to climb this
Travie to climb wait a minute it's
Travis making you look like an [ __ ]
right now you're just jumping up and
down in front of a column then all are
you whistling tech say get me to the
roof Hey look look at that pretty girl
I guess you had a whistle yeah I love it
I just want to whistle really is the
system in the future what the [ __ ] am i
doing I'm just in a courtyard you can't
see yeah
the camerawork is pretty cool you think
so yeah that you can do whatever you
want but like the what Kowski brothers
okay like this I would go right behind
myself and watch okay now now I don't
know where to go okay that's a problem
yeah I know
well why you go upstairs oh this steps
right there looks like it it's out an
incline how about the camera stays
consistent with me are you [ __ ]
conscious I'm literally just running in
circles this is terrible radio and even
worse in real life you don't like the
game no I know I don't think this is my
idea I understand that this is it's a
really it's a it's a well done game as
far as there's no steps yeah but you're
also saying like what am I supposed to
do and you're just walking around the
same like I know but I can't I don't
know how to get down below of the steps
oh we've been here before
we have it was because they can't
control this thing you can yeah it
sounds I didn't leave it says that
you're not taking personal
responsibility no I mean they walk you
up the steps nobody wants to where you
are Jim who walked you up to psych it is
an area with nothing going on
I'll go grab some Zelda [ __ ] look that's
for right now you're praying cool good
please get me out of this game the
goddess statue smiles upon you good for
her
[ __ ] her is that like the movie big you
hope your wish is granted
where's the steps Travis show my sensor
right there get off but how do I get up
to the top there's no top dude it's it's
outside it's the ruins of a castle
there's no second floor in just a roof
you're looking at that's why I asked you
in Travis ed to climb the ladder up only
answer were you saying stuff for we've
got to tell me a little bit
you're defined you're to find things why
don't you get your stupid you know look
around the city Mary I know we ideally
cancel
I want to leave the castle why won't you
I don't want a door it's right there all
right there he's climbing up the wall
all right cool he just took the least
convenient way out of the camera now I
do I just conduct I'm outside the
[ __ ] castle
to the mountains sorry I'm enjoying the
view it's an open world you gotta
explore the open world bro I'm trying to
explore the open world and I don't know
what I'm doing just keep walking I like
that the one thing Jim keeps doing is he
keeps changing the camera angle so you
look from an aerial shot
he loves that aerial shot he does it in
the house to see what else 100 blocks
straight he won't move first of all you
start talking in the third person I'm
talking about the Zelda man know that
[ __ ] thing is his name is link likes
a douche okay now I think we're we're
crossing are we on the the tap cam live
right now yeah we are
okay cool all good it's right now I'm
[ __ ] dead end in this game not done
and you will go right over that wall 100
a book and Instagram live at gym and oh
no now I'm outside and wherever you want
yourself thank you telling you I like an
open world game but where now what am i
doing I'm just running in a [ __ ] feel
like an [ __ ] you put the hair you
look like it is all a rock you fell off
the rocking oh my god where's rocket
help me hello
what is that in the distance oh don't
stop me like this what is that on those
platforms probably nothing but science
stilt I think those are beings to battle
presenters not enough running in this
game well you gotta get to places right
I understand
but not in real life not in real time
hey how do you get the Carnegie Hall huh
Hey we are you trying to get him to come
down to you yeah of course hey come here
I'm not coming up to you Jim what are
you trying to jump up this thing no I'm
figuring out the action [ __ ]
I'm trying to chop this down and knock
them down yeah Oh Kent general right
yeah there's a ladder right across from
you I didn't
there's one of the villainous characters
is on top of a platform and Jim is
having a [ __ ] gammy you think people
wouldn't want to watch no you take it up
on the platform oh it's our [ __ ]
noise hi Haley Oh your mother's Kaena
[ __ ] daddy I know I am so I can't
figure out the camera work take the axe
out you [ __ ] [ __ ] Oh see you're
holding the egg but you gotten hit in
the head so many times with the billy
club or the boat get on them why don't
you use your Boko Club dude I don't know
excited how do you use it listen Boko
claw Jesus he knocked your axe out of
your hand
good game over and over you're done huh
I don't like it so ji-tae just showing
him circles I can't go to the grass you
got killed I got killed good